i'm going to try to be cool like troy
and
periodically oh please don't no it's
like a beyonce on my computer
i'm struggling to not throw up so that
would be helpful if you guys didn't do
that for me or or i'll just stop looking
i play hello everyone welcome to episode
100
of play watch listen i'm alan pierce i'm
a video gamer that's trey baker he's
hungover that's austin wintry cup of
coffee and that's mike bethel who's in
the sunshine which never happens for
this show it's so much worse in the
sunshine i think the the dim light it
looks it looks like a uh
filter you know start counting them kids
like four yawns
it uh wait yeah we're pretty much all
over the world right now right troy
you're in another country not austin and
i we don't go anywhere
we just hang out it's pretty boring um
thank you all for joining us we are live
on twitch uh otherwise you'll be
watching this on
youtube on friday i like that it looked
like mike had to hide what he was
drinking even though it's just he's
drinking just a can of sparkling water
he's just like
delicious
there you go barry is just sparkling
water
yeah but i feel like drinking perrie out
of a can is it quitting because perrier
has historically always come in glass
bottles and i feel it's a little bit
more of an elevated drink than lacroix
which put this are they not
fundamentally the same thing they
fundament well yeah
well
lacroix leans in the direction of flavor
in a way that i think actually expensive
i see
it makes sense
um so i had two things i wanted to start
with the first was i was like i should i
should mention this on play watch listen
this week you know the phrase uncanny
valley
yeah i use it all the time thing i say
and understand when people say it it
only occurred to me this week that i
have absolutely no idea what the origin
is is it a movie oh yeah robotics
what what no it's from robotics of what
it's design the design it was it was
posited by a japanese fellow who i'm
sure chat will post the name of in no
time at all so robotics expert basically
posited that when designing robots
this this this graph basically mapped
from like you know r2d2 to data
and that there was going to be this
awkward moment which we're arguably in
right now where robots look creepy
because they're
zombies so there's always a theory i
haven't missed a movie or a tv show or
something no i mean obviously it's been
quoted in everything ever since but it
was it was yes from robotics originally
because like some people seventies from
a translation of japanese bukiminotani
coined by the roboticist mashiro moti
who created a graphic
look how [ __ ] how how chuffed you are
with yourself mike you're like i'm so
smart right now look at me
with a very small field i i know some
things i'm very very smart about it i
actually am surprised that it comes from
robotics because i always associated it
with
fidelity of specifically faces
uh
and
well it is faces well yeah yeah i just
wouldn't have presumed i think i did
that to come from robotics as much well
they ran into it first thanks to walt
disney didn't they if you think about it
like animatronics and robotics were
there years before we started making
computer graphics that did it you know
they were the first to run into that
problem
interesting
there you go uh we've done it everybody
thanks for tuning in
um so i believe
austin and troy may have to leave us
early but not before
the very first ever i have prepared
play watch listen trivia for episode 100
oh no oh no it's not too bad i made it
pretty easy
it's all right i've not been playing it
i don't know what i said on the show
last week
it's fine no the trivia is about the
show itself so uh jeff if you could get
polls ready because i would like chat to
also uh
try to guess
okay this whole thing wait speaking just
on
we're jumping
from the fallback carry on austin please
since you invoke the name jeff i just
need to call out the the like
ms paint art that showed up on twitter
um
very good i didn't know if it was the
same jeff but holy [ __ ] that it is very
good maybe i can drag that over i always
ask him
yeah i just discovered i was looking at
it this morning and i was like
the little i have this little felt
journey
like christmas ornament that was given
to me by this young girl from brazil
when i went down there for a show and
it's on my shelf and i don't even
remember ever talking about that here i
must have but it's in the thing it's
like four pixels because it's so tiny
but i was like i was zoomed in i was
mother mother of god that's
the whole thing is just i'm in awe i
mean i just needed it i just needed a
publicly my little mario and this dual
sense controller areas have in the
background he's got troy's naughty dog
skateboard
and the recreation of angela's
paintings of jerry goldsmith and leonard
bernstein
almost look like
screenshots like i was like that
to have painted that in paint at an
extreme angle so reduced i'm i almost
got a call shenanigans
it is incredible that that's jeff mccrae
in the chat everybody that's one of my
mods he's one thanks jeff thanks jeff um
who again i also need help from right
now for players listen trivia no more
tangents okay am i wearing a face mask
michael myers
i think i think he's pointing out how
well maintained you're this is all you
put a lot of work into maintaining this
and he's showing respect to that
you're beautiful he didn't put us in
face masks so i think you could read
into that i didn't brush my hair this
morning so i would not i would not sleep
in a mess
the one inaccuracy is that i don't think
i own any red socks honestly jeff
actually go [ __ ] yourself
you know what jeff
you're right
who do you think you are
[ __ ]
um
okay shut up this is a game of who said
the following there are ten oh no i just
want you to tell me who said which quote
okay i've pulled them from across a
breadth of episodes and you're gonna
guess all of them at first oh yeah go
ahead what what what are we working
together as a team or are we yeah i
think i'd like you to give a consensus
and i'm also going to have chat guess
the answers as well
okay
the first one
say that again this is a very dubious
claim
austin austin
that does feel like something i would
say that feels like austin we're putting
in austin that's might be troy on that
one
no no no 100 percent no you can go stim
yeah i'll stop okay i do i do delight in
the word dubious so you
it feels yeah like an austin thing to
say can you guess the context in which
you would say that kind of thing
say that again this is a very nearly all
conversations with people in which they
make clinics i i want to specifically
guess there was something i said
i
asserted something about like something
in history or made some big political
claim
and he was and that's what he was
reacting to i'm gonna make that guess
i'm gonna say that it was some in
response to alana
hmm
well i think it was or
i'll reveal it
i want to make sure we're going to wait
for the answers this is this is pop quiz
we go through it exactly okay uh chat is
also going majority austin okay by the
time we reach the end i will have
forgotten the first question i'll tell
you again i find that i just erase it
it's still here okay okay number two
this is better than game of thrones
house apple has waged war against house
epic
like this is better than game of thrones
house has waged war against house that's
interesting like the two of you troy saw
the other in that yeah
i think troy
let me
your own writing that you're you're if
it is yours you're you're criticizing
it's like that's not a good yeah if it's
mine if it's mine i'm criticizing it if
it's anyone else's then i think it's
really great
that's like the i would never join a
club that would have me as a member
exactly yeah 100
okay uh we're moving too fast for chat
but austin did get chosen for number one
um all right so you've guessed who said
that it was it was mike that we've
guessed for the second one no i'm saying
you're saying me for that one was it
i understood what you were saying troy
there's a lot going on um you said that
somehow our normal chaos is ten percent
above average
it's early it's because we're all very
excited uh so this is better than game
of thrones house apple has wage war
against house epic while putting in mike
i'm putting a mic
yeah i'm willing to all right
tip the majority i really love this one
i'm completely unaware of that entire
conversation but speaking as if i know
what i'm talking
about daffodils
that's a you you thing
i was gonna say me on that one i was
gonna take responsibility maybe you try
yeah
can i ask alana or any of these you
because obviously you've put it together
i did not put any none of them are me no
no no
i actually think and maybe this is me
being slightly self-congratulatory about
all of us but i felt like actually all
four of us could have said something
close to that because i liked that i
liked that i liked that quote i liked
this sort of like i'm uninformed but let
me tell you my opinion yes
i'm gonna i'm gonna disclaim this this
entire show is predicated on that
mindset so that works out
i'm really loud i'm gonna turn myself
down a little bit
you're all right uh
in my recording i mean chat is going
with troy on this one by the looks of it
sounds like something right who are we
gonna put it i think yeah let's say troy
let's go troy go with troy
okay
the next one i never voted i
conscientious
okay i mean that you're allowed to do
that
um for some reason i felt like that one
was you but i i i'll i'll succumb to
peer pressure and say oh no yeah troy
yeah i use big words but uh
austin uses them better so that's why
that's why i say that again this is a
very dubious claim it's austin but i'm
completely unaware of that entire
conversation was because if i okay
the next one you see that do you see the
level
it's like
yeah yeah the chat went with uh went
with troy as well okay next is he can't
help but make music even in a moment of
accident it just arrives
okay
that's a very fast mic there
um
is the rest of your body made whole
is the rest of your body
of your body made whole
i feel like there's some of that missing
that that was it that was the quote
nothing is missing
there's a direct question made whole
who's who's i think maybe austin
the rest of your body made
was i
i don't know why but things delusional
in the moment
it's it's max of austin it's max of him
coming in with a clever pun
oh
yes it's a pun isn't it 100 yes it's
someone who had like a missing body part
or something and he said that's made
them whole
well can an austin i i really like first
austin yes if that's me i will i will
just rely on the cleverness of the
context making it sound coherent because
it sounds can we get can we get the
context can you answer these by the way
alana can we find out yeah i'll give you
the context of this one it makes perfect
sense you have no you need to have no
concerns about the context of that quote
oh it just follows his butt as he walks
away it's it's you know focusing
technology
i respect it chat is split between troy
and austin on that one actually a lot of
votes for troy
did he also just get fancy water did you
also just get i think he's got some
fancy water and some coffee yeah i
believe oh my god i hope he's tipping
well thank you
can we see it the ai let us see how much
you tipped you son of a [ __ ]
yeah
standby
okay
the next one
this one i think is too easy
can i lovingly hold your feet to the
file on a contention that you made
that's awesome i'm i actually 100 feel
like i remember saying that actually
i'm walking in austin
uh that's 100 i think that's the easiest
one not that not that i'm confirming
that i wouldn't do that until after
we're done so who knows it could be
anyone
who knows yeah
wait a minute so chat got a little clue
there that's fair enough that's
reasonable i felt like when troy said
i'll be right back and the camera
followed him to the edge of the frame i
felt like i was in the pov of a dog that
sort of like has that wistful like are
you leaving forever as it tracks and
watches you
walk away and then now having been
convinced gone forever just the gaze
wandered back over to the center of the
room yeah it's so sad now we're just
staring at the wall having existed
just so clearly a hotel room i always
wonder how they do that you know how you
could see a picture like that like in a
short film or whatever and you're like
that's a [ __ ] hotel it's just always
so clear that the decor is hotelie
i feel like there is a certain midwest
grandparent
potential to that room though yeah i
could i could they'd have more they'd
have more art i think or messier
i think only because of the cushion
austin i think because the the because
the cushion color wise it's just a
little bit wrong for the wall behind it
it has that kind of
human place there's like a floor
as opposed to the perfection that is
hotel decor
like a hotel is like boringly on brand
right whereas like often like hey we had
we have yeah
on the wall or whatever yes in vegas so
i don't know that hotels are flipbook
houses because you get different assets
in different rooms you can put them
together and get a video it's true yeah
boring is
we'll take it not a gift that's a nice
map though i think if that's what that
is
i think so yeah i don't know
computer enhanced all right um
well i want troy to be able to
participate so we can we can we can just
continue to talk about the decor you can
analyze the decor yeah anyone have any
other anecdotes to share about the decor
uh people in the chat are currently
antagonizing me by saying who
recommended inscription i'm pretty sure
it was austin which is very rude
very i am just trying to expand your
horizons
and and uh you know make sure that you
have all the good games on your radar
i think it's fair that i think as long
as austin austin can have all the credit
but he has to get all of the blame for
when we say something stupid i think
that's the fair and reasonable
be the lightning rod to both i mean i've
certainly read my share of comments
declaring my lack of
understanding of this that and the other
uh i enjoy getting into it on those and
saying uh well you know link me an
article and a good number of times
people do yeah yeah yeah i see those and
mike occasionally comes in it's not not
i always get i
yeah i don't i i tend to only ever
comment angrily so i tried correct that
is true yeah well austin has a bit of a
better spread it's hard not he's
balanced it out better yeah it's hard no
i'm just not i like the experience
someone said i'm enjoying the quiz i
assume austin organized it
get out of here how [ __ ] dare you
you're my fault
but somebody else did say thanks alana
for making thomases alone it's my
favorite game hey
anytime a great job there wish list
ending sucked a bit but the rest of it
was pretty good well done yeah but all
biffle endings suck that's you know
that's what they say
up to and england i believe that mike i
don't care
i don't believe in the heart i'm just
making a reference to stephen king
saying that about himself okay i didn't
say that i actually think that
i'm sorry
it's all right i've also read that book
and not unfortunately i've read that
book and i know you're not making that i
mean look alana is a writer you are
making it's very fast thinking and
therefore i want to give you the credit
anywhere thank you she just you know the
you know the supposed um
was it mark twain who was it that that
had the sort of
the dying words of uh on the contra
someone said you're gonna be fine you're
gonna make a full recovery and they say
on the contrary and that was their dying
words who i can't remember who
uh who who's that you know purported to
have been i feel like it was
mark twain but i can't remember either
way
uh alana just gave you yours
bedside all all mike bithell endings
suck
these need to be the last words out of
your mouth uh yeah but i feel like i
just have the credit that's all i'm
saying
okay no i'll take full credit it'll put
a little music video like lower left
hand attribution uh
in the frame
thank you
um all right we're gonna go with the
next one
you obviously can't show a rough cut and
expect to get any meaningful feedback
from like an audience of normies
i would never say normies so it's not me
i would never say normies
you owe them i guess it's a lie
it wasn't me you obviously can't show a
rough cut and expect to get any
meaningful feedback from like an
audience of normies
like makes me think troy
yeah i mean i was a token valley girl
but he said it like an audience of
normies that's how troy sounds that's
why you guys
this is acting
it's just barely holding it up
any no guesses for this one at all i
mean i guess i'll go with me my funny
enough it felt like it felt like a it
felt like
mike said that
but the and the normies was
intentionally like was you being i was
hanging out
or referencing someone else that said
normies
because there's an intrinsic there's an
intrinsic uh sympathy to the creative
process from a
you know filmmaker which would have a
certain
yeah you know camaraderie with a game
director i could have been that if i if
one of you had said normies in like the
last couple of sentences or something i
was kind of riffing off what you said
yeah it could be could be all right i'll
go i'll go with that
none of these are from our show at the
end of this
turn out to be from a totally different
podcast
yeah it could be um
it's a it's just a beautiful opportunity
for people to give us [ __ ] and i don't
know why
that's me
that's a straight vote for troy there i
feel like that's me i'm not gonna
maybe yeah
it's just a beautiful opportunity for
people to give us [ __ ] and i don't know
why that yeah
i i feel like
the beautiful is what tips it to troy if
if it it some other word my instinct
probably would have been that that was
you alana but something about calling it
a beautiful opportunity does
these are all kind of funny excerpts i
feel like that first of all we shouldn't
have asked that question
because i
knowing that it has to be one of the
three of us and that alana's not there
changes the rules for sure
it's true and i i didn't include myself
because i thought that if i did that i
would have some inherent bias in what i
picked
like i picked them so randomly and i was
like but if i try and pick them myself
i'll probably like order them
differently or i could unintentionally
pick different things to try to be like
oh don't let them know it's you whereas
i wasn't doing that with anything i
selected i was worried i would become
biased yeah like if you're like
integrity of this process is pretty
important
yeah it's important to maintain
standards isn't it yeah we didn't get to
100 episodes with like standard values
yeah yeah and integrity guys and rules
yeah integrity
that's what all our reviews say
integrity
um so we we're going for troy on that
one because it's beautiful
sure next
one of you has to get rid of that that's
a good sentence
by the way we're going to go with troy
for that one because beautiful book is
beautiful
the next one is one of you has to get
rid of the others pawn collection if
they die
that's a troy
no i think that's actually awesome i
think it might be me
who are who is it
so the reason i think is because i was a
massive fan
because it's a because i was a teenager
i was a big fan of a tv show in the uk
called coupling which none of you will
have seen um correct and that was one of
my favorite episodes is about the
characters like deciding that so it
feels like something that would be in
the back of my mind as like a joke i
don't know
a lot of microphones maybe there's a
chat on this one a lot of microphones i
think they're great
i'm easily swayed
all right
um the last one is i like going into
rooms where they're arguing about really
difficult subjects
which i felt was the most generic and
broadly applicable
i like you say that again for me i like
going into i like going into rooms where
they're arguing about really difficult
subjects
i'm fairly certain that that's me and
that i was talking about clubhouse
interesting
uh
in the
yeah if i had to guess
between you two for me
austin
okay i feel like i remember
it's true it it i haven't been on
clubhouse in a while but that would at
the height of my curiosity with it that
was
that was basically the central interest
in me is is going into super kind of
debatey contentious spaces so i feel
like
it could have been me if it wasn't
in which case i have no idea
okay
uh it's anses time
say that again this is a very dubious
claim you are correct is austin
that what do i get was the episode where
uh we were talking about
troy said that there were electric cars
at the start of
the century
and that was austin's immediate response
say that again this is a very dubious
claim
um
the next one is this is
giving me some potato skins for winning
that one so clearly it's true
we're doing pub quiz
this is better than game of thrones
house apple has waged war against house
epic was troy and it works if you have
the context of he did a cute little
voice when he said it
so you guys guessed mike yeah you did a
house i said troy i said troy
it was troy it was troy
um
that's very clever i'm very proud of
that
i think yeah i feel like if you told us
and the per just to note the person who
said this did really good voices while
they were doing it he did probably would
it would that would have been a good
idea
i am completely unaware of that entire
conversation but speaking as if i know
what i'm talking about which you guessed
was troy
was mike
no it's a mic wow i would never admit
that out loud what was it what was i
talking about it we were talking about
uh controversy relating to the crisis
remastered trailer people being upset
about how the graphics looked um oh so
you were saying i don't know anything
about this but here's probably what
happened
um
the next one he can't help but make
music even in a moment of accident it
just arrives you guessed mike
and you are correct it is mike and he
was referring to austin
who like
dropped something and it made some kind
of drumming sound it did
uh is the rest of your body made whole
you guessed austin
and it was troy and there is technically
an extra part of that quote that gave it
away too strongly that it was troy so it
was in reference to me when i [ __ ] my
hands up and i was like look i don't
have to wear bandages anymore and you
said is the rest of your body made whole
and then it was something like as the
lord would say or something like that
and i was like that makes it too clearly
troy we can't put that part in um and
then i went on about how my knee was
still in [ __ ] shake
can i lovingly hold your feet to the
fire on a contention that you made
was austin indeed what was in reference
to a video that i made on my channel
that was the very opening sentence of
that episode can i lovingly i think that
was about uh the stock market it was uh
i remember i was a whole extra hour out
of that i was buying i was buying [ __ ]
from my studio at ralph's listening to
your video on headphones i think you
texted me i was like there are things i
want to follow up on here and you did
yeah um you obviously can't show a rough
cut and expect to get any meaningful
feedback from like an audience of
normies
you guessed mike
was actually austin
said very plainly
very plainly i'm not proud of the like
being noteworthy enough to be quoted i
think the like is also probably how you
came up with the normies is that you
were like i don't know you're thinking
about like
normies i don't know labs should i call
them but i did think that was a tough
one to guess because no one says that
word very much
um
it's just a beautiful opportunity for
people to give a [ __ ] and i don't know
why you guessed troy and the answer was
troy
correct that's beautiful
because beautiful i'll hang on let me
note that on the answer sheet because
beautiful of course yes
one of you has to get rid of the others
porn collection if they die you guessed
mike and the answer was mike um and it
was actually in the reference in
reference to troy and austin's
relationship
i'm saying that like they're close
enough that one of them has to get the
point if they're not trying to make
sense yeah because they are that close
them as funeral friends
yes
and yeah i remember that and
mike and i went what does that mean and
mike goes that means one of you has to
get rid of the other's porn collection
if they die
that's a clever joke
what's what's so funny isn't it stolen
from the tv show coupling from yeah now
it all comes out doesn't it now
i didn't come up with that joke
what's funny about that is that it
doesn't really the the the sentiment i
understand but even the the
the phrasing of it doesn't work because
it's like
well
you can't go to each other's funeral
because
one of you can
funeral friends
yeah like someone's gonna let somebody
else down do that yeah that's true
exactly
like one way funeral really come to your
funeral
uh well unless i don't know yeah i can't
even commit
barring one previous engagement
uh and they actually
they're my mind the final one is i like
going into rooms where they're arguing
about really difficult subjects you were
correct was austin and was in reference
to clubhouse yes
so you got uh
most of them right i mean i'm not really
tallying this you mostly did really good
chat also largely got them right good
job everybody across the board where'd
it go were there any chat got right that
we didn't get right you know i wish i
knew enough about how twitch works to be
able to look that up but the truth is
that i don't i have no idea but it was
very funny to just like scrub through
episodes and what i did was just look
for people smiling in the freeze frame
and then just found a quote this is how
it felt when i did the uh the sort of
like musical uh
one i remember i remember going
i remember
i i i almost didn't do it because i
thought
there's just
so much content what am i gonna go back
and rewatch them all or it seemed it
just seemed like i don't there's no time
for that i don't want to subject myself
to that
really selling the show to previously i
know right yeah
what would i well yeah but what i wanted
this crap
what i discovered was that i could
literally just click on a random episode
plop to a random moment in it and almost
immediately there would be something
that i would think oh this could be
funny if i put like this instrument
below it it was it actually
it was actually
i just did it completely at random and
and found because i thought i want stuff
that's kind of memorably funny or or
weird little things and and uh it turns
out we do that non-stop turns out we're
just seminars
well that's been the show it's been a
good 100 uh episode
a lot of you feel like you wanted to
spur us on to another part of the
conversation no i was going to say troy
we all just cut you off
because we did like three times when you
were trying to speak what were you
trying to say oh
i was just i was curious if i could
guess what i did while i was off camera
but it's not really that important i
assume that you don't want to open that
carol of worms on chat what's a carol
did i say carol i said i think i tried
to say a can and then a barrel
or did you do something more interesting
or all your visits to the bathroom more
interesting
there you go let's go with c on that one
who had who had troy throws up on the
100th episode in their bingo
oh did you really
that's great oh my god i stood up to get
that cup of coffee and i was like here
we go oh no you're the only way when
you're like on the ride so it was great
so we're why didn't you keep the audio
open that would have been
no that would have been a good musical
that would have been austin's next audio
death metal oh my god you're that hot
are you okay actually what we should
have done is all four of us like based
on the audio alone who is this throwing
up
i think we need i i will say this i'm a
very uh a respectful vomiter i it's it's
uh
there there are people that i know that
it's it's uh it's uh that's gonna be an
easy one to guess a hundred episodes
from now by the way i'm a respectful
vomiter oh that's a good one that's a
good one that's detroit no only troy
could have said that
yeah but defined wise what you know what
you you uh
fairly quiet
i keep it to myself i don't want to
bring in other people
uh and then by putting it on a live
stream
however many people are watching this
yeah 1 200 of you for joining us uh i
appreciate that
are you feeling better for it though is
it helpful oh yeah you ever get to that
point where it's just like oh yeah i
know exactly yeah it was it was a
wonderful night and uh
i'm in calgary oh nice
canadian canadian uh and there's a great
restaurant that was it was highly
recommended and so i went and uh i was
like hey here's a pop quiz uh how much
wine do you have and can i have all of
it
uh and so they were they were uh
grateful or and well yeah they were
grateful and uh and they were gracious
enough to share
their bounty with with us
and i think we went through four bottles
of wine between three people and there
were other people at the table that were
not drinking but it was so there's a lot
to celebrate 300 episodes of the show i
presume
that's exactly what it is
the following morning yes
and then i i literally woke up this
morning at 6 30 and i did like that full
body
diagnostic i was like where are we at
and i was like i think i'm going to be
okay and then i remember that we were
doing this
i'm so sorry i literally said to myself
i was like well at least it's not live
whenever i'm hungover i just sit in the
shower for a long time i'm also a pretty
quiet vomiter but i
accidentally accidentally i just want to
say that like it's not in a means of
being dramatic i cry while i vomit
unintentionally i will cry while
vomiting triggers that yes i'm not doing
it because i'm like actually emotional
about it i just cry while i vomit so
whenever i'm hungover it's sit in the
shower
occasionally vomit on myself in the
shower which is not the best and then
just sort of cry by a toilet bowl it's
great i feel like your technique needs
some
yeah yep
some it also wakes me up really early
and when i started drinking as a
teenager um which my parents didn't
really care about because they don't
care in australia i would always shake
when i was hungover and my mom one time
was like are you on drugs she's like no
i just no no no no oh god it wakes me up
at like 5am it sucks
but i'm not the one who's hungover
that's all troy i did recently have a
meeting where i just turned my camera
off and went and threw up because i had
a migraine but i didn't want to miss the
meeting
basically basically that's basically
what just happened but that's true the
wistful gazing
that's true
yeah
don't follow me camera you don't want to
see that did you still have the airport
did you hear about
battlefield mine to be
like that's one to see
for sure i think what we would have held
there i think there was there was
one second of me was like do i take them
with me
no i don't
that's that's that's a respectful
vomiter right there no if you needed to
i would have understood
this is the content people i know vomit
yeah 100 what i especially love is that
that uh
troy being absent for
a couple in a row this is a perfect
comment
i am unapologetically back
[Laughter]
on the show i did want to ask and i hope
that the answer is
yes um has anybody seen uh everything
everywhere all at once
no i just saw the batman we can talk
about that
wait would you say what
the batman
oh my god do we never talk about the
batman
we may have never spoken about the
batman
no i don't see the oh it's just you and
i troy did you like it
i loved it interesting there was a time
so travis travis william and i went to
go see it and
as if it was a synchronized planned move
movement um
bear with me
we at the same time
both went
looked at our watches because i was like
and there's even a fun fact it's like it
is now the longest running movie in the
batman franchise ever i'm like wait it's
really 175 minutes it could have been
cut down yes the last third is
unnecessary sorry 175 so that's just
three hours three hours i've heard and
i've heard that it's
i haven't felt motivated to see it
precisely because i've heard that you
feel the weight of that time you do at
the end yeah uh pretty
yeah pretty heavily my plan is to like
watch it i think you can now good i
think it's on agent yeah well it's hbo
it's on hbo max in these states right
yeah i'm gonna visit kerry and we'll
just like chill out and have an evening
watching i don't know if i want to see
the cinema for three hours to watch it i
like having you know the ability to
pause you know it's good
but um it makes sense i saw i saw end
game which is like three hours opening
night at that race is past i think it
was but it was like we went i went to
like a 1am showing um oh okay and for
the i i had to i had to take a piss for
about the last two hours of that movie
and it was a it was a painful experience
by the end it was one of those where
it's one of those where you're so far
past that you have a hard time fully
standing upright you're kind of frozen
in this hunchback position but i was
like i'm i'm i am not bailing i i refuse
uh it's just so long i mean i think it
was wasn't it hitchcock that said
uh the length of movies will always be
constrained by the size of the human
bladder something along those lines yeah
absolutely
you never know what to say that sounds
very hitchcock you all really please do
go say everything everywhere all at once
i think it's un-ironically for a while
and everyone said that to me before i
saw it so i was like there's no way
it'll live up to this hype and it did
it's in oh really and even with that
hype it was well she's incredible she's
very good absolutely it's so good it's
ridiculous um
the batman i liked but didn't love which
people got very mad at me for um
and i think that my main criticism is
there is there is there a loud audience
around the dc movies i've never released
as it turns out was the not even was it
was it that people wanted you to like it
more or like it less is the concept that
it sucks or is it yeah no people were
like wow i can't believe you hated it i
didn't i just didn't love it um which
well anything less than either extreme
is right it's a nothing truly an
internet problem um
it's a lot like
seven but then it doesn't oh yeah like
it's a lot like a lot of movies like
that um
almost cosplaying as them but then i
don't think hits the core of any of them
quite as well so it sounds very clear to
me this is my your inspiration is all of
the for sure joke is a great example
because that's i'm watching and i'm
thinking of every scorsese movie i loved
and how it's not quite up there with
scorsese yeah and that's what it felt
like to me was like okay this is
like there are some some things that i
really really really liked about it like
i think the tone of gotham in it is
[ __ ] awesome but the things that i
it's a total it's liverpool right
yeah it is
was it really yeah i think it was
showing liverpool because i remember it
was like local news here like whenever
they were filming liverpool um i
as well because i love the planet the
apes trilogy he did well he only did the
second and third one right but they were
excellent
those were pretty shockingly that that
was it that is
an underappreciated in the realm of
reboots and remakes and whatnot that's
an underappreciated gem where all three
of those i felt like were excellent i
really enjoyed it
no
strong strong trilogy yeah
i i i loved that they were juxtaposing i
would sorry
almost leave two of you out of this but
it was the first time when they were
like what if gotham isn't chicago would
have got them as new york and it had
this very much of like we're changing
[ __ ] up um i liked how they pulled from
jeff john's or one
and like the relationship between he and
alfred
um
i'm not a big paul dano fan oh my god
he's one of my favorite actors dude did
you see prisoners
i love that
and i didn't like him in this
yeah i just i saw him working and i saw
him
um i i hate to be critical because i
don't ever want to be presumptuous about
what he was going in but it it felt to
me as if
either he inherently had this awareness
of
all of the
pressure and and the onus of like look
what heath ledger did for joker and
liquid watching phoenix zipper joker and
that's the standard that you have to hit
either that was you know inherent in an
incumbent
by his own you know
um
desire or
it was
the director telling him this is what
you need to
hit the scene in the
[Music]
where he's on the ipad i'll try to avoid
spoilers um yeah he asked to reshoot
like
numerous times um because he was
effectively doing a one-man play so i
think it was probably his own pressure
again he's legitimately one of my
favorite actors he's in my top five i
love him like there will be blood he's
so good oh god
okay but in
the what about batman i felt like next
door
he's in the girl next door
yeah he's the elijah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah with the porn star that
moves yeah i know that yeah with emil
he's like emil hirsch's there's two guys
that are like his two best friends and
paul dano is one of them no way
because the whole the whole thing at the
end is he's like he's super lanky and
skinny and awkward and very nerdy and
the whole thing is that they they do
they shoot like a sex ed video
um for the that's like the sort of thing
at the end of the movie right and so
there's this there's this uh this this
is the bit at the end where
they like apparently get naked on camera
because you see all the kids
like faces as they watch the screen
and it's they're like
wow like
damn and you just see him and he's like
oh yeah
it's like just one of those just funny
that was like my introduction to who he
is where i just thought
yeah that's i remember that that's
pretty that's pretty well pulled out but
then i saw prisoners the danny
villeneuve movie and it was like okay
he's actually a real actor yeah i love
him um in
in uh the batman
the whole
kind of in-cell sort of theme um that
they go for a little bit with with some
of the riddler stuff is like a bit weird
anyway but he
yeah he's just he's closer to the joker
than the riddler and he's just very over
it's i don't know it's just a difficult
character to be like what is this
what are you what are you pulling from
it's just strange
it's strange it's tough to live up to
jim carrey though isn't it
well
truly
um joel schumacher is the gold standard
he's a lot more like
joker than
i think he would have wanted but it i
mean it's still different and then he
you know he's wearing like a
sex dog
[Laughter]
it's a strange one beautifully shot
though my god that movie's absolutely
gorgeous yeah a lot of things that i
really liked about it
uh i really got to give it to pattinson
because he just
it worked
it i i i
to though generally he's a very good
actor he really is and i felt like he
was not trying to do anything that was
pre-existing but he was not rejecting
what had you know come before him
so he
uh his bruce wayne
was really good are you going to vomit
again
[Music]
i saw her but i panicked
some of the chats had colin farrell as
well yeah colin farrow was awesome he's
he's and he's always great i liked him a
lot um i also liked robert pattinson
though i don't know that i was a huge
fan of the iteration of batman i blame
none of that on robert pattinson
it's an interesting movie
are they doing more with this cast are
they doing more pattinson
robert rob
my favorite podcast calls him yeah
yeah i mean they definitely they
definitely look like it i made a lot of
money
yeah i would assume um troy this is a
good question that we got from chat too
did you ever get off the train
in jedi fall in order
no
that's a great question
a hundred episodes later it's so funny
because i um the games that i like right
now i went back and i i don't know if we
haven't talked about this or not but
i started playing assassin's creed 2 on
my switch
nice
and
i know yeah how is it aged
not well man it's a shame it it has
nothing to do with
they dated their own games by improving
on them so much every iteration
um i could you could say improving but i
think you could also um
inflating and bloating
sure but i mean just like the parkour
and the combat happens to all of us troy
yeah can't relate since assassin's creed
too stand by oh my oh have fun
oh
i love it the camera follows it
uh mike
the last of us
never no i i do need to go back you
really should because at the time it
definitely it was good it was it was
right at the start covered it was like
just a stressful and it's a bummer of a
game i fully understood why you didn't
want to i do need to go back to it
though for sure because covert's done
now so the panda makes over so have they
done the standard kind of 60 fps ps5
patch for it that might be a good reason
to go back to it go back and play it all
silky smooth i do not know
i will austin look into that i have no
questions for you
as we know austin's just so well behaved
um he just he gets all the homework done
is there anything austin's missed i i i
just leave everything on the table
there's nothing left to be uh curious
about
i would just like to point out and i
really do have to jump off but i would i
would just like to point out that that
first episode in which we talked about
the train
was two and a half years ago i know it's
actually weird looking at some of the
earlier episodes because you can see
that we've aged
i was like oh
speak for yourself alana i think uh i
think
had two [ __ ] years that we've been
doing this show oh my god like it was
very it was like it was like late
november or wasn't it it was that we i
was 12 when we saw
i was in like my uh kitchen my setups
changed so much like it was very weird
troy was in a different house in a
different country exactly i did want to
before he was in a different house i'm
the i'm the one stable
yes exactly not entire
my background squares are very uh
very crucial to the
yeah that's true everyone else has moved
around the aesthetic um so before we
lose your austin even though i know like
probably already looked at this uh lenin
um
[Music]
they
did they send this to you first mike
i've had very little correspondence with
lenin do you say lennon
the person who submitted the statistics
their user name is lennon oh that was me
wasn't it someone sent that to you yeah
and i believe their username is lennon m
um they
sent a link saying for anyone interested
in weird data here's the link to view
the intro stats that i've been tracking
along with a few other metrics so they
put together this document that's super
super cool that has uh
our attendance records which is alana 97
austin 99 troy 86 mike 97
very good uh
around every 10 minutes yeah my lack of
a hundred
keeps me awake at night great coco would
have been here it'll become
statistically less relevant as time
moves on though you'll be fine but you
can never get that i'm digging up no you
can never get it it's impossible you
can't go up to 100. you've missed one
we could really balance the strategy
game
no it can't happen around every 10
episodes the show seems to be introduced
at the start
um which is interesting more noticeable
among streaks of later intros and then
we have the um the frequency of when the
show has been introduced so uh if it's
introduced in the first quarter it's
higher than i thought
uh 46 percent
and i think that's the early episodes we
used to do it more often and then we
came up
second quarter ten percent third quarter
is three percent fourth quarter is 39
and then no intro is three percent i
guess there are three episodes
it's episode nine
episode 37.2 which is technically
technically a bonus
and then yeah we've got um austin intros
are listed as well so there are a few
austin intros some troy intros there's
never been
a mic intro
mike you've never introduced the show
have i never done that no
no there you go
yeah um
but we can we can probably wrap it up
now if you would like to
to let you go austin hey troy welcome
back how was that
oh it's hilarious you good
yeah
and i mean respectful not polite
oh come on
come on hello
can we
uh we did already do the intro on this
yes we did we've already done that
camera move that zoom is amazing
yeah my body just looked at me and was
just like really dude you're going to
drink coffee right now
i feel like coffee usually helps
with the hang of them not today
always a bad idea
so we still have to figure this out but
we are currently trying to see if we can
finagle doing an episode live with an
audience
you know yeah man
um so we thought that we would let
everybody know that
at the forum or at uh yes of course
naturally uh at the hollywood bowl yeah
yeah
no it'll be a smaller venue than that we
will keep you updated i would say follow
the twitter account which is at peace
yeah well maybe
we will hopefully do that at some point
during may but we still have to figure
out a date that works so we're working
on doing that it would be awesome it
would be super cool um otherwise i'm
currently having the second animated
shot animated and i should have that in
the next two weeks or so
exhausting austin is in it i made sure
austin was in it it's a good one i'm
very excited about it i can't wait to
see it it's a little bit longer than the
first one as well
and it's actually a feature film being
produced by dreamworks yeah it's cost me
a fair bit of money
yeah
we will debut it live in person um the
other thing was ah i can keep the other
surprise there was another thing that i
was trying to do for this episode that
the timing didn't work out for so yeah
we're live we made it happen troy
vomited on the podcast you what did what
else did you [ __ ] want iconic thank
you yeah happy 100
how about a large [ __ ] train rolling
past
hell yeah that's cool is it like a good
train like an ice train
no
no
by the way
anybody
who uh if you ever see the words opulent
and historic
in a hotel
description that just means old yeah
yeah
first time kerry
first time kerry booked a trip for me uh
work trip just to help me out and she
booked me into a place called the good
hotel not knowing how americans named
their hotels it was not a good hotel it
was like it was good hotel in the spirit
of the good place
you were in trouble oh she's like it
must be nice to disappear into the hotel
they would lie i will end the show you
can you don't have to well okay fair
enough
more concise and all right to look after
so thank you all for joining us live
happy 100 episodes thank you to the
three of you for joining me for two
[ __ ] years
it's wild
um and we will see you i don't know next
week maybe who knows anymore
there you go for recycling no less